[Applaudissements]
enfant je suis littéralement envahis par
mes émotions je vis avec ses émotions en
permanence alors en piste mais journée
mes rêves un simple regard pu me rendre
joyeux mais un mot me blesser à jamais
et c'est vrai je pleure assez souvent
malheureusement ce qui me permet de
percevoir ce manque autour de puma une
faiblesse dans le miroir que sont les
autres peut-être à cause de mes racines
italiennes
un petit garçon ne pleure pas surtout
l'aîné de la fratrie à 5 ans le petit
garçon doit s'endurcir
en suivant les traces de son père au
club de judo c'est une épreuve à chaque
fois mais je me souviens de cette sortie
en voilier à ses muscles et partant de
mistral avec un ami qui me disaient de
la poésie du baudelaire
pendant que je gérais la situation
disons critique souvenirs incroyables de
flou entre performance pure
sa poésie et les émotions je ne le
perçois pas mais je rentre docilement
dans le moule de notre société pour
survivre cette faiblesse émotionnel à
apprendre ce qu'est aux autres je
construis ma carapace pour garder
confiance
quel monde bizarre je devienne une
véritable machine en particulier dans le
milieu difficile complexe
ce que j'apprécie particulièrement votre
même texte je suis capable de me montrer
aucune émotion pour aller vers
l'objectif je peux même être dur avec
les personnes qui m'accompagnent une
faiblesse alors en 2002 avec plusieurs
associés nous créons une entreprise qui
réalise des confinement des structures
temporaires comme celle ci
impressionnant nous forçant le respect
dans l'industrie et je veux mon
entreprise humaine à l'ecoute nous avons
créé une forme de monstres moderne pétri
de procédure le système iso avec cette
course folle vers la performance
ko harmonie au quotidien la confiance
est fragile et incertaine les
collaborateurs sont loyaux mais usé
fatigué nous irons même jusqu'au clash
alors quelques années auparavant je
rencontre une personne assez
extraordinaire il s'appelle eric baronne
il est champion du monde de vitesse et
de descentes en fait en vtt et nous
travaillons ensemble sur l'aérodynamique
pour battre des records de vitesse comme
celui ci en 2002 122 km heure sur neige
en 2002 il se projette sur un nouveau
record sur terre cette fois il le bat
encore d'actualité aujourd'hui 172
kilomètres heure mais à quel prix
au passage des cellules la course à la
performance pure a failli lui coûter la
vie lors nous nous reconstruisons l'un
et l'autre et nous retrouvons en 2013
pour travailler sur à nouveau la course
aux records
montesquieu disait pour réussir dans le
monde
il faut avoir l'air fou et être sage
alors nous notre projet les simples
battu le record du monde avec du travail
beaucoup de travail en 2015 fin mars
2015 les conditions sont difficiles mais
il tend ce record du monde eric établi
223 km/h sur neige avec succès
extraordinaire une satisfaction
personnelle
incroyable quel soulagement après tout
ce travail
mais quelle frustration un seul petit km
heure nous sommes encore dans la
performance pure c'est difficile parce
que nous sommes usés épuisé par la
tension à la pression au moment de l'
annonce du record je suis auto qui au
sommet je m'effondre 30 minutes
inconsolable c'est un vrai choc
émotionnel
une porte s'ouvre à nouveau en fait vers
un nouveau monde je dirais quelque chose
que nous allons exploiter
nous allons l'utiliser l'année d'après
nous décidons de faire collaborer les
artistes et les techniciens de nuit à la
pleine lune sans lumière artificielle
nous devons utiliser tous nos sens pour
nous connecter les uns aux autres il
permettra eric de tracer cette courbe de
lumière éphémère dans la montagne c'est
un déclic nous connecter à notre sens il
fait nuit on ne voit rien on doit être
en connexion les uns avec les autres
c'est un déclic pour lui une ultime
tentative que nous allons lancer l'année
d'après pour cette tentative
ce que nous voulons c'est faire monter
la dimension émotionnelle
cette puissance là et l'associer à
l'équipier déjà hyper technique hyper
performante alors nous travaillons sur
un management un petit peu différent
plus de fluidité de travail en même sur
nos sens nous créons une sorte de
expérience émotionnelle dans lequel nous
retrouvons tous nous créons notre tribu
une véritable tribu est ce qui est clé
dans une tribu c'est que les égos
pourtant puissant ici vous l'imaginez
les egos et face il ya moins de pression
moins de tension on respecte l'autre il
n'ya pas de jugement l'une management et
souple les difficultés sont effacées
avec une fluidité déconcertante
alors nous y sommes cette tribu vous
voyez là elle est constituée elle est
efficace
eric le champion fait partie de la tribu
nous sommes tous là prêt pour le jour j
avec l'intensité des émotions qu'on peut
voir ici
3 2 1 go 228 km heure puisque 4,5 km à
quelque chose de phénoménal
eric que c'est dépassé l'équipe c'est
dépassé mais d'abord bravo monsieur
varone bravo aux teams à respect surtout
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
il risque sa vie et que s'est il passé
au fond comment avant
nous pu créer cette sorte de connexion
alors vous imaginez nous sommes très
technique bien sûr pour atteindre ces
objectifs là alors on a équipé plusieurs
personnes de capteurs des t-shirts
bourré de capteurs qui nous permettent
de connaître notre rythme respiratoire
notre hymne cardiaque
notre position dans l'espace et à partir
de là donc eric et équipe et je suis
équipé aussi au sommet une troisième
personne qui tient le vélo est équipé au
sommet une quatrième mathias en bas il
est à un kilomètre
et puis un photographe professionnel de
sports extrêmes qui est juste à côté de
nous il prend des photos il est à un
mètre il est vraiment plus près lui est
arrivé juste la veille il fait pas
vraiment partie de la tribu mais il
connaît le monde de l'extrême regardez
ses courbes rapidement le stress
physiologique de toutes ces personnes là
nous voyons première étape 5h24 du matin
un brief que nous faisons avec eric
juste pour expliquer que nous y sommes
nous sommes là le stress physiologique
chute deuxième moments clés nous
arrivons au sommet de la piste
nous craignons qu'ils y ait du vent tout
le monde craque et du vent au moment où
jeanne lorsqu'il n'y a pas de vent le
stress physiologique chute à nouveau
troisième moment clé le record du monde
nous sommes tout synchroniser tout
synchronisé cardiaque mans tous sauf un
vous avez devinez qui c'est celui-là
passer une journée extraordinaire le
photographe c'est la courbe en
pointillés blancs vous la voyez là c'est
clair il n'est pas dans le même monde
mais il a passé beaucoup beaucoup de
plaisir donc un projet il a deux
dimensions clés qui sont très
complémentaires la première ses
dimensions de technique elle est à
l'arrière elle permet sur lac se fixe
d'avoir la fiabilité et la régularité si
tout ce qui est technique ingénierie
marketing finance tout ça qui nous
permet d'atteindre l'objectif
la performance pure la deuxième
dimension elle est humaine
c'est celle qui nous permet de piloter
d'éviter les obstacles d'anticiper mais
aussi de prendre le mur ces deux
dimensions là quand on les combine nous
permettent d'atteindre des objectifs
l'ultra performance dans lequel nous
associons deux choses le résultat
opérationnel bien au dessus de ce qu'on
peut imaginer et l'accomplissement
personnel très élevé plus haut niveau
alors
face à tout ça vous imaginez que dans ma
façon de travailler de fonctionner avec
des entreprises
il supervise le projet j'ai changé ma
façon de faire depuis des années ce
soi-disant cette soi-disant faiblesse
émotionné elle peut être au fond la
force des grandes réalisations des très
grandes réalisations leader
charismatique providentiel monde cherche
c'est une chimère de notre société ultra
performant ça l'est dans le collectif
elle est atteignable oui ce monde qui
est vraiment vraiment bizarre de côté
nous avons des organisations qui nous
happe et qui sont tournés vers
l'efficience au mépris de notre
émotionnelle de ce même côté de l'autre
côté ces mêmes organisations elles font
en sorte que l'on ne tombe pas dans le
stress qu'on évite les burn out alors on
nous aménage des espaces de détente de
méditation pour se sentir bien du team
building
cela me fait penser à apocalypse now ce
film dans lequel en massacrent les
populations et aux clips et en soigner
les rescapés pour donner bonne
conscience on est dans le même schéma
alors face à ces nouvelles grandes
réalisations toujours plus ambitieuses
qui nous attendent nous devons
réapprendre à nous tourner vers de
nouvelles formes de coopération dans
lequel chacun est reconnue pour son
excellence technique mais aussi
émotionnel dans lequel nous pourrons
converger dans lequel chacun trouve du
sens et du plaisir
la confiance en soi dans les autres dans
l'avenir c'est à nous tous de l'imposer
demande bizarre à nous tous rené char
écrivait en 1950 un pote à chance serre
ton bonheur et va vers ton risque à te
regarder ils s'habitueront
merci
[Applaudissements]